okay this is just saying the Hannity if
you or anyone you love is thinking of
applying to law school you must be
having major second thoughts today three
professors prattled on about how Trump
must be impeached eleven months before
an election their delivery was
alternatively angry dismissive and
tedious
despite the wall-to-wall coverage and
relentless hike by the Democrats today
soporific symposium cratered any hope
that they're going to coax Americans
into supporting impeachment here are the
top five reasons you know it's over
first today's legal experts tried to
pass off as facts flimsy theories and
unsupported inferences and they use
those theories and inferences to
conclude that the president should be
basically removed from office the phone
call itself of July 25th is
extraordinarily clear to my mind in that
we hear the president asking for a favor
that's clearly of personal benefit
rather than acting on behalf of the
interests of nation and acting on his
for his own personal benefit and not for
the benefit of the country he invited
the Russians who are a longtime
adversaries into the process the last
time around because he has invited the
Ukrainians into the process and because
he suggested he would like the Chinese
to come into the process into the
process well Stanford law grads should
demand refunds for any class taught by
Carlin without corroborating evidence
well she's presuming malign motives on
the part of President Trump when an
equally plausible motive could be that
President Trump as the nation's chief
executive has every right to want to
know whether Ukraine meddled in the last
election and it's for that theory that
the president somehow was trying to
personally benefit from his dealings
with szalinski Joe Biden wasn't and
still isn't Trump's political opponent
in the next election he's one of several
so how can they so definitively claim
that this was president Trump's guiding
sole motivation answer they cannot
second you know it's over when three out
of four legal eagles
were Trump hating partisans Pam Carlin
she was basically Elizabeth Warren
supporter gave $1,000 to her last summer
and Trump's rapid response team dug this
up when Carlin admitted she was
triggered by the mere sight of the Trump
Hotel building in Washington I got off
the bus from Dulles down at L'Enfant
Plaza and I walked up to the hotel and
as I was walking past what used to be
the old post office building and is now
that Trump Hotel which I had to cross
the street of course but sure triggered
she was in the Obama DOJ as well Michael
Gerhart formed from UNC law school he
once ran media efforts for Al Gore he
also worked for the Bill Clinton
presidential transition team in the
1990s Noah Feldman a professor at
Harvard Law School has been arguing for
impeaching Trump for years he even once
speculated that Trump could be impeached
over a tweak that he sent claiming Obama
you know had wiretapped his campaign but
beyond their bias there was a nasty
bitter undercurrent that bubbled to the
surface again from Professor Carlin well
the president can name his son Barron he
can't make him a baron she later
apologized but still couldn't resist
taking a jab in her apology at the
president now contrast those partisans
with the GOP witness Professor Jonathan
Turley he's not a trump supporter he
voted for Clinton and Obama but that
made his methodical takedown of the
impeachment sham all the more convincing
the record does not establish
obstruction in this case if you accept
all of their presumptions it would be
obstruction to impeach a president on
this record would expose every future
president to the same type of inchoate
impeachment if you make a high crime and
misdemeanor out of going to the courts
it isn't abuse of power it's your abuse
of power third you know it's over when
even the Democrats press haunters are
admitting this thing's a hard sell the
notion of having four academics in the
broader goal that Democrats have to pull
the public along on the idea of
impeachment I can't see it changing
fourth you know it's over when the
Democrats were straining to invoke the
founders the founding father George
Mason asked shall any man be above
justice and Alexander Hamilton wrote
that high crimes and misdemeanors mean
the abuse of violation of some public
trust Adams wrote to Jefferson John
Adams once wrote to Thomas Jefferson
James Madison said that impeachment was
needed Hamilton got a whole musical and
William Davy is just going to get this
committee hearing
aren't you just devastated that Obama
didn't put her on the Supreme Court
you've heard of the school of rock right
well she filled in a Gerhardt we're
starring in law school of crock I think
we just put in the jury pool the
founding fathers I don't think we have
any idea what they would think if you
were going to make a case to George
Washington that you can impeach over a
conversation he had with another head of
state I I expect his hair his powdered
hair would catch on fire
it says form of necromancy that that
academics do all the time nice use of
the word necromancy fifth you know it's
over when Democrats after all of their
outlandish claims still won't say how or
even if they'll vote I'm going to
reserve any kind of a public judgement
it's important that we
no decision hasn't made as to whether or
not we go forward with impeachment
they're lying I don't know but a better
explanation is that they want to give
themselves an out or at least some
wiggle room perhaps got to see what
those latest polls are looking like they
say the founders but what they're really
relying on our focus groups this thing
has gone south and they all know it but
this has been a great 24 hours for Trump
yesterday he was dominating the agenda
over at the NATO summit pushing for more
member nations to pay their fair share
we all love that last night he was
mocked by foreign elites in London today
he was mocked by academic elites on
Capitol Hill shuck up another win for
the White House is there any way by the
way we can get that lady from Stanford
to come back and lecture us some more
tomorrow and that's the angle